mai 2020 das aus für das atomkraftwerk
philippsburg
das ende der kernenergie in deutschland
ist besiegelt für kernkraftgegner ein
grund zum feiern
auch die neue regierung mit den grünen
setzt weiter auf den ausstieg aus
atomkraft und kohle die erneuerbaren
sollen es richten haben sie ihren
wählern versprochen was ist das ziel und
das ziel ist klimaneutralität bis mitte
2014 und dieses ziel müssen wir
gemeinsam erreichen ganz anders in den
meisten eu-staaten 108 atomkraftwerke
hängen noch am netz allein in frankreich
sind es 56
flamanville an der normannischen küste
auf einen granitfelsen zwei
druckwasserreaktoren in betrieb ein
weiterer soll bald ans netz immer wieder
kam es zu bauverzögerungen mit rasant
gestiegenen kosten und auch
sicherheitsproblemen doch anders als in
deutschland bleiben die meisten
franzosen eher gelassen in dem kleinen
hafen dem dem atomkraftwerk kann man das
hören
ich denke wir sind hier die sicherheit
sehen sie mein mann arbeitet schon seit
30 jahren in der nuklearindustrie und
wir fühlen uns hier sicher
wir brauchen die atomkraft unbedingt
denn sie produziert schließlich kaum co2
bei euch in deutschland gibt es noch
immer kohle das ist schädlich wir haben
in diesem jahrhundert den planeten schon
genug kaputt gemacht
paris auch die französische regierung
hat versprochen den klimawandel zu
bekämpfen
allerdings mit mehr atomenergie in einem
exklusiv interview erläutert wirtschafts
und finanzminister bruno lemaire wie das
gehen soll
das ist eine strategische entscheidung
das ist eine richtung
es geht darum 2050 die co2 neutralität
zu erreichen
gleichzeitig erwarten wir einen
steigenden bedarf an elektrizität in den
kommenden jahren um beides zu erreichen
co2 neutralität und den steigenden
strombedarf haben wir entschieden neue
atomkraftwerke zu bauen
frankreich kämpft dafür dass atomanlagen
als klimafreundlich und nachhaltig
eingestuft werden darüber wird gerade in
europa verhandelt ein neues regelwerk
die sogenannte taxonomie soll festlegen
welche energieerzeugung in zukunft ein
grünes label bekommt
das ist sehr wichtig denn die
investition in neue akw sind sehr
kostspielig wir reden von zweistelligen
milliardenbeträgen
wir sind in übereinstimmung mit der
europäischen taxonomen die investitionen
als klimafreundlich ein spurt wenn sie
keine co2 emissionen verursachen und
dazu gehört die atomenergie das ist auch
wichtig unter finanziellem gesichtspunkt
die investoren brauchen hier sicherheit
ohne privates geld kann frankreich den
ausbau der atomenergie nicht stemmen
viele investoren aber wollen nur
langfristige und nachhaltige projekte
finanzieren sagt philip gisdakis
anlageberater bei der hypovereinsbank
wenn kernenergie als nachhaltig
klassifiziert werden würde wird es
bedeuten dass unternehmen die
kernenergie produzieren
in diesem geschäftsfeld engagiert sind
in
nachhaltige anlagestrategien
berücksichtigt werden und das würde
bedeuten dass die aktienkurse
entsprechend steigen dieser unternehmen
und das würde auch bedeuten dass die
kapitalbeschaffung wird für diese
unternehmen einfacher
atomstrom als nachhaltig darüber wurde
auch auf der un-klimakonferenz in
glasgow gestritten deutschland und vier
weitere eu-mitgliedstaaten laufen sturm
gegen die französischen pläne
doch offensichtlich dass atomkraft nicht
nachhaltig ist es dann das gibt bessere
alternativen wind und sonnenenergie
deshalb brauchen wir eine taxonomie die
anderen kraft ausschließt
doch deutschland und seine verbündeten
sind in der minderheit umgeben von
staaten die atomkraft als nachhaltig
sehen die ministerin versucht es mit
druck in brüssel schickt einen brief an
die eu-kommission gemeinsam mit
luxemburg dänemark spanien und
österreich erinnert sie an tschernobyl
und fukushima in dem brief heißt es die
kernenergie ist mit dem in der taxonomie
verordnung verankerten grundsatz keinen
signifikanten schaden zu verursachen
unvereinbar
was sagen die grünen zu den brüsseler
plänen schweigen anfragen von frontal an
das führungsduo blieben unbeantwortet
der osten europas setzt auf atomenergie
zum beispiel die slowakei die anlagen in
mochovce sollen erweitert werden im mai
hat die slowakische
atomaufsichtsbehörde die inbetriebnahme
eines weiteren reaktorblocks genehmigt
die regierung in bratislava hat wenig
verständnis für die deutsche haltung zur
atomenergie
und mal ganz ehrlich zu sein ich kann
nicht verstehen wie man so dumm sein
kann dass man seine eigenen atommeiler
abgeschaltet die voll funktionsfähig
sind in der slowakei die von die vier
atomreaktoren zurzeit 55 prozent des
stroms und dabei wird es nicht bleiben
ein fünfter reaktor soll in ein paar
wochen dazu kommen in zwei jahren ein
sechster
und dann wird der anteil des atomstroms
auf 70 wachsen und somit mehr strom
produzieren als es selbst verbraucht
da fällt es der slowakei leicht abschied
von der kohle zu nehmen das war einmal
eine zeche und ein kohlekraftwerk
2023 viel früher als in deutschland sei
schluss verspricht die regierung dann
erinnert nur noch eine waschkaue an
bergmännische vergangenheit doch alles
hänge daran dass atomkraft als
nachhaltig eingestuft wird
wenn er tonquellen nicht als nachhaltig
eingestuft werden wird ihre finanzierung
anspruchsvoller also schwerer zugang
auch wenn sie zugänglich sein wird wird
sie viel teurer sein als andere
energiequellen das würde auch bedeuten
dass es eine investoren geben würde die
in atomenergie investieren
das wiederum kann die weiterentwicklung
der atomenergie aufhalten
im kampf für mehr atomenergie haben die
slowaken verbündete neun eu staaten
stehen auf der seite frankreichs und der
slowakei am 11 oktober erscheint ein
offener brief im französischen figaro
zitat
wir brauchen die atomenergie um die
schlacht um das klima zu gewinnen sie
ist die beste waffe in diesem kampf
unterschrieben von 13 ministern aus neun
ländern
deutschland steckt in einem dilemma
durch den atomausstieg und das
vorzeitige ende der kohle droht eine
lücke die durch wind und sonne nicht so
schnell geschlossen werden kann im
übergang sollen gaskraftwerke den
fehlenden strom liefern
aber es gehört auch für eine längere
zeit dazu dass wir das nutzen und dass
wir auch neue gaskraftwerke errichten
doch wer gas verbrennt produziert auch
co2 klimaneutral ist das nicht trotzdem
soll gas als grün gelten fordert die
alte regierung was die neuville unklar
die grüne europa abgeordnete anna de
panne kritisiert die öffentlichkeit
seien nicht informiert worden was da in
brüssel verhandelt wird
atomkraft und gas gehören beide nicht in
die nachhaltige taxonomie das ist
eigentlich nonsens ist zu behaupten es
geht ja darum dass wir die mittel zur
verfügung stellen wollen wo es hingehen
soll in die neue welt und da ist es ja
total unlogisch dass wir quasi das was
wir eigentlich überwinden wollen mit
frischem geld was in richtung
nachhaltigkeit gehen soll noch einmal
bezahlen das deutsche dilemma ist der
französischen seite nicht entgangen
ich kenne die empfindlichkeit der
öffentlichen meinung in deutschland bei
dem thema atomenergie ich glaube es ist
sehr wichtig miteinander zu reden wie
wir das zwischen deutschland und
frankreich immer machen um am ende ein
kompromiss einer einigung
so könnte es ausgehend die franzosen
bekommen grüne atomreaktoren und die
deutschen grüne gaskraftwerke